fans of retro gaming are excited for hi
Perkins upcoming retro 5 console which
supports no fewer than 10 different
gaming formats from the past
there's Famicom Nintendo Super Nintendo
genesis/mega Drive Game Boy Game Boy
Color Game Boy Advance Super Famicom the
list goes on it's due to come out
quarter 1 of 2014 which might mean April
but it seems that with this extra time
for development users will actually
benefit with the new redesign hi Perkins
added a little bit of extra plastic in
the back that will allow the controller
to rest when it's not in use or allow
users to put in a Sega Master System
adaptor something that was requested by
a lot of fans of hypercam when talking
to the hyper can wrap it turns out that
the Android operating system inside the
retron 5 won't be completely locked down
already there are a lot of options for
users such as choosing different regions
and Genesis and Mega Drive games
applying graphical filters saving States
in the middle of a game among other
things but if users really want to they
can get inside a debugging menu and
install custom operating systems for the
retron 5 with custom roms users will be
able to do all sorts of things such as
apply patches to games including
translations for games that were never
released in America of course this might
also mean support for roms something
hyper Kane is not willing to support out
of the box but they admit with the
Android operating system which isn't
protected very well users will be able
to do so if they wish it's only a few
more months before the retron 5 comes
out and classic gamers everywhere should
get their hands on this console for only
a hundred bucks well we haven't had the
chance to thoroughly test it yet it
already looks like one of the most
interesting pieces of hardware coming
out in 2014 for fans of classic gaming
stay tuned and GameSpot for more CES
coverage i'm peter brown thanks for
watching